vous avez un continue voici le rappel
des chiffres de cette édition la rentrée
sociale avec le oui mais de la csdc au
pacte de croissance proposée par michel
rocard et le non plus sec de jean kaspar
aux propositions union de la cgt
henri krasucki sera notre invité en
direct de lyon pologne c'est enfin
officiel quatre postes de ministres pour
le parti communiste 12 pour le syndicat
solidarité c'est la composition du
gouvernement conduit par mazowiecki est
personnalités personnalisé aux
agriculteurs du sud-ouest de la france
pour henri nallet la sécheresse cette
année nettement plus grave que celle de
enfin un football avec les matches
éliminatoires pour la coupe du monde
qualification de la yougoslavie
début donc dans ce journal met tout de
suite les malheurs de danièle gilbert
qui a passé la nuit dernière en prison à
nice l'ancienne animatrice de télévision
a été inculpé d'escroquerie et de
publicité mensongère pour une affaire de
bach porte bonheur dont elle vantait les
mérites dans certains magazines à
talisman vendu 189 rend la publicité
assuré argent bonheur miracles d'année
gilbert faisait part de son expérience
personnelle
en fait les quatre cents mille balles
vendues dans le monde entier n'ont pas
toujours tenu leurs promesses et les
plaintes se sont multipliées le
préjudice porterait sur 80 millions de
francs danièle gilbert est passible
d'une peine d'emprisonnement allant
jusqu'à cinq ans elle encourt surtout
une amende pouvant s'élever à 2 millions
de francs
et c'est l'incrédulité en tout cas à
chamalières dans le puy-de-dôme la
population ne veut pas croire à une
quelconque culpabilité de sa célèbre
concitoyennes là j'ai connu daniel
gilbert à la ftf où j'étais speakerine
est vraiment ma surprise a été immense
il
al'annonce de son arrestation parce que
je considère que danièle gilbert et
c'est une fille honnête je ne vois pas
où elle a été maître les doigts la lie
je crois qu'elle a dû subir des
influences et se laisser embarquer dans
une histoire dont elle n'avait pas
imaginé les conséquences alors tombé sur
pour aider de largeur mais reconnaît mme
fatema parce qu'elle a pas forcer les
gens à doha les acheter et pas de
bêtises moi je trouve que ce sont ces
gens c'est thomas qui chope aux crédules
ou quoi si on arrête tous les gens qui
vendent des des bagues des porte bonheur
et tout ça il va falloir d'abord
supprimer les journaux qui vendent ce
genre d'article et à ce moment là les
prisons sur place est grande pour mettre
tous ces gens là en prison et d'une
manière plus générale ce sont en effet
les marchands de bonheur qui sont mis à
l'index dans cette affaire et surtout
les conditions dans lesquelles ils
promettent des solutions miraculeuses à
tous vos soucis
le véritable miracle bien souvent c'est
d'être remboursé si vous n'êtes pas
satisfait alors quel mauvais greenhalgh
a tenté de remonter cette filière des
grigris vendu par correspondance
un marché florissant qui s'appuie sur la
seule crédulité des gens des gens qui
n'achètent pas du rêve
à tout seigneur tout honneur pour
remonter la filière des bijoux du
pharaon et autres grigris nous nous
sommes tout d'abord rendu à l'adresse
qui figurait sur la publicité vantant
les mérites de la bac de ré mai au 17
rue de musset à paris aucune trace du
centre national de parapsychologiques
cherche le centre national de
parapsychologie elle est occupée par une
seule société et les responsables
visiblement de bonne foi nous expliquent
qu'ils n'ont jamais reçu le moindre
chèque destiné aux marchands de bonheur
le courrier aurait été détourné à la
source les associés de danièle gilbert
tiennent à rester discret jean n'avons
jamais été dans mes bureaux
autre recette miracle cette fois pour
maigrir autres vedettes du show biz pour
en vanter les mérites notre deuxième
tentative et plus fructueuse il y à bien
quelqu'un à l'adresse indiquée mais
manifestement notre arrivée provoque un
certain émoi les dirigeants la société
qui s'enferme précipitamment à clé
affirme pourtant qu'ils n'ont rien à
cacher mais refuse de nous montrer la
moindre échantillons de leurs produits
monsieur g le témoignage nous avons il
ya des gens qu'on a des clients qui ont
maigri j'ai bon évidemment je vais aller
sortir des journalistes parce que ça
vous regarde pas mais si un jour un juge
d'instruction de pose des problèmes nous
avons les témoignages des gens qui nous
écrivent et sans indiscrétion ça me
paraît quand sa vie se permet de gagner
correctement sa vie par tout le temps
non je réponds bien alors les grigris
les gogos les petites croix vita fort et
autres pierres du nord sont elles
constitutifs du délit d'escroquerie ou
de publicité mensongère
la parole est à la défense la loi de
1973 sur la publicité mensongère ou sur
la publicité trompeuse n'est pas fait
pour défendre les naïfs
si demain vous allez voir une voyante un
marabout parapsychologue et si
d'aventuré six mois après les
prédictions de cette personne ne se
réalisent pas j'imagine mal que vous
iriez devant le tribunal correctionnel
ou même dans le cadre d'une action
civile en responsabilité professionnelle
pour vous plaindre de ce manque de
talent et je vous rappelle donc que
danièle gilbert a été inculpé
d'escroquerie et de publicité mensongère
à l'étranger 12 membres de solidarité et
quatre communistes dans le gouvernement
de monsieur mazowiecki en pologne le
poupe parti communiste obtient les
ministères qu'ils souhaitaient sauf
celui des affaires étrangères
par ailleurs le parti paysan eric de
quatre ministères le parti démocrate
recueille deux portefeuilles bref après
trois longues semaines de tractations la
pologne dispose enfin d'un gouvernement
nathalie darrigrand 23 ministère pour le
gouvernement tadeus mazowiecki dont 12
pour solidarité ou ses proches et 4 pour
le parti communiste
une victoire pour les compagnons du
premier ministre pas si simple car le
poupe obtient encore la défense
l'intérieur les transports et le
commerce extérieur en temps des quatre
postes clés contre la culture
l'éducation l'industrie le travail les
communications pour solidarité seule
grosse surprise dans cette répartition
le ministère des affaires étrangères qui
revient à un proche du syndicat
peut-être même à un membres de
l'épiscopat polonais l'information est
encore à confirmer
reste que ce ministère voulu par les
communistes leur est cher
ap un plus certain pour solidarité qui
en revanche est comme prévu laisse aux
partis politiques en la justice
l'agriculture l'environnement et la
santé
le premier ministre doit maintenant
convaincre les uns et les autres du bien
fondé son choix une tâche qui s'annonce
très difficile notamment avec les
parlementaires de solidarité avec qui il
est actuellement en réunion
la lutte contre la drogue s'intensifie
en colombie voici les télégrammes de
l'étranger préparé rédigé et commenté
par jérôme cathala
cet homme étroitement encadrés par des
policiers américains s'étaient devoir
dormir au martinez
le trésorier présumés du cartel de
medellin son extradition vers les états
unis est un nouvel acte de guerre du
gouvernement colombien à l'encontre des
barons de la cocaïne
on s'attend maintenant colombine à une
nouvelle vague d'attentats en afrique du
sud les affrontements entre policiers et
manifestants noirs dans la région du cap
aurait t 25 ou 23 morts selon
l'opposition
les journalistes ont affirmé avoir vu
des policiers tirer dans la foule depuis
leur véhicule
quant aux résultats des élections
législatives dont les noirs étaient
exclues c'est le parti national qui les
a remporté le parti national au pouvoir
depuis 41 ans mais qui a perdu le quart
de ses sièges autres élections
législatives aux pays-bas le premier
ministre chrétien-démocrate loubert sort
vainqueur pour la troisième fois
consécutive
justin mais son allié le parti libéral
recul et la nouvelle coalition
gouvernementale pourrait bien être de
centre gauche
le général aoun chef du gouvernement
militaire chrétien a demandé des excuses
aux états unis après que l'ambassade
américaine à beyrouth et est évacué hier
le département d'état américain avait
rendu le général aoun responsables
passés à l'évacuation en affirmant que
la sécurité du personnel américain
n'étaient plus assurés personnes ont
trouvé la mort en espagne dans des
inondations et des pluies torrentielles
se sont en effet abattues sur le sud est
espagnol aujourd'hui notamment sur
l'andalousie et l'archipel des baléares
la rentrée sociale en france avant de
rejoindre henri krasucki en direct à
lyon la conférence de presse de jean
kaspar secrétaire général de la cfdt qui
a sèchement décliné la proposition
d'unité d'action formule précisément par
la cgt discours tout empreint de
modération si jean kaspar a distribué
quelques bons points au gouvernement ils
réclament en tout cas davantage de
justice sociale
c'est donc un oui mais de la cfdt au
pacte de croissance proposée par michel
rocard ministre se rassure s'il a besoin
d'être rassuré nous ne voulons pas faire
sauter la caisse la cfdt veut que les
marges de manoeuvre qui existe
aujourd'hui sur le plan économique soit
utilisé pour répondre aux aspirations à
plus de justice sociale qui se manifeste
dans différentes couches de la
population
il y à là quelque chose d'insupportable
de constater effectivement les progrès
importants en matière de redressement
économique et dans le même temps
l'accentuation des inégalités
l'augmentation du nombre de ceux qui
sont laissés au bord de la route du
progrès économique et social
il est donc plus que temps que les
salariés les chômeurs touchent les
dividendes des efforts qu'ils ont
consentis durant ces dernières années un
fossé nous sépare il est vrai de la cgt
quand henri krasucki déclare que la cgt
est prête à rechercher des terrains
d'entente possible sur des sujets
brûlants et que cela ferait beaucoup de
bien pour l'efficacité des luttes
revendicatives nous conte
sidérant qu'il s'agit d'un coup de bluff
alors le secrétaire général de la cgt
est en direct de lyon henri krasucki
vous l'avez entendu en fait jean kaspar
vous demande ce que son veau sans
changement d'objectif ou de stratégie
qui pourrait justifier l'unité d'action
c'est tout simple les salariés sont en
train de se mettre en mouvement parce
qu'ils sont mécontents ils éprouvent le
besoin d'agir et quand ils veulent agir
ils souhaitent que les syndicats
s'entendent plutôt que restent divisés
nous les comprenons ils ont raison c'est
pourquoi la cgt dit il est vrai que nous
avons des positions différentes on l'a
entendu à l'instant avec ce que vient de
dire jean kaspar sur le gouvernement par
exemple
et pourtant il soutient certaines
revendications tant mieux nous disons
essayons de nous rapprocher pour aller
dans le sens de ce que souhaitent les
salariés certes main tendue ce n'est pas
du bluff c'est sérieuses et loyales
elles restent tendues et d'autres ont
répondu d'une façon plus nuancée
certains positivement comme la cftc et
puis faut laisser un peu les salariés
faire lors leurs oeuvres et le temps
aussi la réflexion ce que dirait on a
l'impression que la cgt est un petit peu
isolé quand même parce qu'il ya une
forte convergence entre fo la cftc la
cfdt la fen la cgc et la cgt qui
n'arrivent pas à rejoindre l'ensemble
des syndicats avaient goûté
moi ce qui m'importe c'est d'être avec
les salariés qui agissent parce que
c'est eux qui tiennent la clé de tout
quelles revendications quelles actions
et comment faire et aussi l'unité alors
là nous ne créions absolument rien nous
sommes en plein dans le coup avec eux et
si d'autres organisations syndicales qui
l'ont tentée en dehors de 10mm d'action
commence à en parler et bien et c'est un
qui ont un problème pour rejoindre le
mouvement réel mais nous voulons leur
facilité s'ils le veulent bien
s'ils le veulent pas les travailleurs
jugeront men où je pourrai polémique et
je ne veux pas la main reste tendue et
je dis à jean gaspard
il ne faut pas dire fontaine je ne
boirai pas de ton eau surtout si cette
fontaine est en train de devenir un gros
temps là en ému
votre réponse au pacte de croissance
proposée par michel rocard en une minute
j'ai pas besoin d'une minute ce n'est
pas impacté ce n'est pas de la
croissance pourrait faire sauter la
caisse henri krasucki de quelques aises
parlez vous la caisse des casinos la
pièce de la bourse à caisses des banques
de l'économie française j'ai entendu des
gens qui passent par dire un peu la même
chose que ce que je peux dire tant mieux
dans ce cas là que des salariés
constatent que d'une part les profits
augmentent on nous parle de dizaines de
milliards pour des opérations qui ne
crée aucun emploi où personne ne sait ce
que c'est un média maintenant c'est
énorme et tout ça là ils se disent les
c'est nous qui l'avons créé cet argent
là c'est riche et cela alors et nous
nous voulons ce qui nous est dû à son
réseau en tout cas l'unité d'action dont
est loin par exemple denain
contrairement aux autres syndicats la
cgt refuse de rencontrer paul quilès
pour la réforme des ptt
oh là là il gagne
vous gagnerez à être très attentif à ce
qui va se passer demain et par la suite
sur ces questions là parce que
rencontrer paul quilès dans les
conditions où il le fait ça non parce
que il veut essayer d'opposer des
syndicats les uns aux jo au pour le
moment le personnel refusent massivement
massivement le rapport en question et
des différents syndicats sont amenés à
prendre leurs distances et même à
prendre des positions nettes compte pour
l'asim sur écran alors qu'ils pensaient
bien c'est pas un problème d'isolement
un isolement comme celui-là 20 ça va on
se porte pas mal nous cherchons à
rassembler merci monsieur krasucki
d'avoir été l'invité du 19/20 le
ministre de la justice se réserve le
droit de poursuivre le député européen
du front national claude autant-lara
après ses déclarations dans le mensuel
globe
évoquant le génocide juif claude
autant-lara affirme le site
en tout cas ils ont raté la merveille
madame simone veil a préféré aujourd'hui
ne pas commenter ces propos qui ont
soulevé un véritable tollé de
protestations oui alors notamment à
bruxelles le président du parlement
européen s'est dit horrifié par les
propos tenus par claude autant-lara ce
dernier avait donné sa démission
parlement ce matin il devrait
s'expliquer prochainement dans une
rouverte la sécheresse nettement plus
grave qu'en 1976 dans certaines régions
du sud ouest de la france henri nallet
le ministre de l'agriculture annonce des
mesures ciblées et une aide
personnalisée de l'état avec la volonté
de tenir compte des besoins réels des
agriculteurs alors au total une douzaine
de départements devront se partager en
fonction de leurs besoins
une enveloppe de 290 millions de francs
et dès lundi les préfets pourront
appliquer ce plan d' aide aux
agriculteurs se fait dire au total 290
millions de francs vont être répartis
dans les jours prochains entre les
régions les plus sinistrées soit la
moitié de l'enveloppé globale promise en
conseil des ministres le 23 août dernier
pour l'instant la liste des départements
qui bénéficieront de cette première aide
n'est pas encore définitivement établie
henri nallet a seulement précisé qu'ils
étaient une douzaine et que les cas les
plus urgents se trouvaient dans les
régions midi pyrénées languedoc
roussillon auvergne et aquitaine
c'est une dernière réunion avec les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
qui déterminera vendredi matin les
départements prioritaire une réunion qui
risque fort de tourner à la foire
d'empoigné
le nombre d'agriculteurs touchées par la
sécheresse s'élève à plus de 300 milles
répartis sur 40 départements
henri nallet a tenu à rappeler que pour
le reste de l'aide gouvernementale
il faudrait attendre la fin du mois afin
de mesurer l'impact de la sécheresse sur
les productions fourragères
mais si les évaluations des dommages ne
sont pas encore terminées une chose en
tout cas est sûre l'été 89 aura été une
catastrophe pour l'ensemble des
agriculteurs français
la rentrée scolaire j + 2 lionel jospin
ministre de l'éducation s'est rendu
aujourd'hui à heyrieux une petite
commune de l'isère où il a assisté au
premier cours de langue
reçus par des élèves de cm1
l'apprentissage de l'anglais est en
effet l'une des mesures prônant cette
année par le ministre de l'éducation
dans son plan d'orientation en fait dans
les autres écoles primaires ce système
va se mettre peu à peu en place mais
d'ores et déjà une expérience pilote a
été tenté l'année dernière à
châtellerault dans la vienne les
enseignements de cette nouveauté un
guillet retrouver ses élèves
bien chanceux qui se retrouve cette
année en sixième je viens du tout du
nord de l'allemagne au bord de la mer
andreas est la nouvelle la nouvelle
institutrice allemande
elle viendra deux fois par semaine dans
la classe de cm2 de l'école jacques
prévert pour les séances d'initiation
premier contact la ville vient comment
faire en un mot un an après en sixième
ces élèves ont été les premiers à
apprendre l'allemand à l'école prévert
l'an dernier leur rentrée linguistique
au collège est une première c'est très
intéressant parce que on peut démarrer
beaucoup plus rapidement et surtout ce
que je trouve c'est que ils ont la
motivation c'est à dire qu'ils ont envie
d'apprendre cette nouvelle langue
l'idée emballe familles et parents mais
dans la pratique
l'instituteur se transforme en
équilibriste une discipline de plus sans
allonger les 27 heures hebdomadaires ni
toucher aux matières maudite art et
sport
le temps n'est pas extensible mais je
pense qu'il va falloir qu'on cherche
vraiment intégrer ça dans les programmes
en allégeant que les programmes
d'autrefois
de toute façon la performance n'est pas
en vue la véritable finalité de
l'initiation est temps de préparer
culturellement et psychologiquement
l'enfant à l'étude d'une langue au
collège où est présent le tour de france
de l'actualité avec les commentaires de
lens pika
deux lettres anonymes envoyées au
ministre de la défense cette fois ci par
des sapeurs pompiers de paris
ils dénoncent la centaine d'heures de
travail effectuées par semaine la
vétusté des logements et le poids
écrasant de la hiérarchie les
signataires de sous-officiers qui se
défendent de toute manipulation
politique
deux légionnaires découvert assassiné
sur l'autoroute a50 de hauteur de fuveau
dans les bouches du rhône
les deux hommes ont été tués par balle
avant d'être carbonisés une des victimes
seraient de nationalité allemande
les légionnaires étaient en permission
hébergés à la caserne d'aubagne un
hold-up ce matin dans l' agence
principale du crédit lyonnais de lille à
deux convoyeurs de fonds ont été
agressés par trois hommes masqués et
armés
leur butin environ 400 mille francs
ouverture à bordeaux de la convention
des tsiganes il s'agit d'une fête
chrétienne traditionnelle ouverte à tous
5000 itinérant attendus nombreux sont
ceux qui participent aux vendanges dans
la région enfin grandes manoeuvres à
chantilly avec la première épreuve du
championnat du monde d'hélicoptères cinq
pays en compétition ou presque puisque
les états unis raflent tout sur leur
passage admirer l'élégance un slalom
avec un seau rempli d'eau un petit jeu
de quilles aérienne ensuite dans le
mille ah bon sport avec tout d'abord le
tennis et la défaite de yannick noah la
nuit dernière en quarts de finale des
internationaux des états unis trois sets
secs face à le désormais célèbre boris
boum boum
et oui boris becker 6 surpasser noah
était quasiment absent du match il faut
remonter à 1932 pour trouver en
demi-finale de l'open des états unis un
français et il s'agissait d' henri
cochet très drôle maintenant avec la
grande soirée européenne hier soir pour
la qualification en coupe du monde après
l'argentine l'italie et le costa rica la
france vous savez et éliminer la
yougoslavie a obtenu son billet pour le
mondial les italiens et la belgique a
fait elle un grand pas vers la
qualification en revanche le phénomène
hooligans est à nouveau d'actualité
jean philippe guillard les tristement
célèbres hooligans anglais ont suivi
leur équipe nationale jusqu'à stockholm
pour assister aux matchs éliminatoires
de coupe du monde contre la suède avant
la rencontre ils ont effrayé les
habitants et brisé quelques vitres de
voitures mais dès le coup de sifflet
final
la police a interpellé les plus excités
d'entre eux et les a raccompagnés ce
matin jusqu'à la frontière
sur le terrain les deux équipes n'ont pu
se départager
malgré des occasions de part et d'autre
score final 0 0 dans ce groupe 6
l'angleterre est en situation favorable
c'est la pologne qui jouera le rôle
d'arbitré
les yougoslaves eux sont certains de
voir les stades italiens en juin 90 mené
1 0 à la mi temps par l'ecosse
les joueurs de sim poussé par 40000
spectateurs ont su réagir à temps et
marque 3 fleurs par catane est là qu
bellic et l'arrière guilhem city va
détourner dans ses filets un centre
faisait la priorité pour terminer une
action en continuité qui montre la
technique et le sang froid des belges
l'illustration parfaite du jeu rapide et
collectif à bruxelles les diables rouges
ont écrasé le portugal 3 à 0 un but du
pullman et de buzz vanderlinden sauf
accident la belgique disputera elle
aussi le mundial tiercé quarté +
aujourd'hui à vincennes tout de suite
les résultats et les rapports avec le
case le 7 le 11 800 21 francs 50 et puis
le quartier plus pour ajouter le 4 et
vous gagnez 7582 france ce soir sur
l'a34 in notre histoire un film de
bertrand blier et puis soir 3 23h25
présenté par philippe dessaint et puis
sachez qu'il faire 3 rendra un hommage à
georges simenon le 8 septembre prochain
avec la diffusion du film de gilles
grangier cents à la tête avec jean gabin
ce sera à 22h50
demain le 19/20 vous sera présenté par
élise lucet gérard pinson nous vous
retrouvons lundi bonsoir écrit dans ce
far et